but that was the fun part my friend  would jizz on captains or whatever their  pillows and stuff and they will sleep  and sometimes he will put like pews  pubes  in his mouth that was the fun part you  enjoyed we would jerk off together we  bonded so you had a true circle we  weren't looking in each other's eyes  you're sleeping but on other sides of  the bed going like this yeah but we  would put like a towel down and then you  jerk off that side i joke off this side  and when we're done we high five  bro you're trying to finish at the same  time yeah you go are you close  and he goes not yet and i'm gonna go  okay  and then i uh  i wait a little bit